evan bliss
alan sarkin
that was a great conversation we just
had on self-realization
i love that one yeah that was uh i think
we both felt a lot of energy after which
i believe is a good sign
that we really uncovered some valuable
things
yes it was great when we were talking
about it a moment ago it's
as though we both undergo
the dialectic in order to augment our
own models concepts
frameworks world views plus
in that process we create great
analogies metaphors yeah relatable
expressions of it for other people
for both ourselves and for other people
and
yeah so on it's a net net win for
everyone all parties
exactly yeah and
it's great because now we juxtapose a
conversation about self-realization
with now this conversation which is
about
dating yeah there we go my gosh i love
that
we both had to grin when he said that
right yeah and
giddy school children getting school
children
it's interesting because even dating
is so intertwined with self-realization
totally yep and we're going to unpack
both the good and the bad
yeah of dating it's a topic that
is super mainstream right now because
people
going back to biology have
had to undergo mate selection
yeah in order to breed for the next
generation
to continue the cycle of life
but in modernity especially
the whole idea of
[Music]
deciding if my 1
should become 2
first question would be why yep
first of all start with one start with y
and second of all would be
transparency and clarity with that
other one person not only about that why
but also about that how long
that's the other one because what's the
intention
is critical because it decides on the
length because if the intention is the
the one night satiation
of primal demands and
then there's that versus the i'm
literally doing this because i want
i'm only selecting what could be my mate
that i breed with
yeah so huge spectrum of
choice here and in a very spiritual
sense
i would like to say a lot of people have
used
the terminology called twin flame
and so
i like that a lot i feel like we should
use that throughout the conversation
and the twin flame terminology typically
indicates or signifies when
your
choice to enter into
dating is
for the y of
becoming more self-realized becoming
more
self-actualized becoming more
of an incredible expression of god
here and then
if you would like to breeding with that
person and having
it's just a footnote for you alan huh
and being a good parent
well being a good parents are very
important all right there we go yeah
so so that would be i think a nice
spectrum from the very limbic sort of
one night
styles all the way up to this like
divine twin flame ascension
so i think there's an interesting middle
ground too like
i think there's partners romantic
partners that we have for a season right
like yeah what are your thoughts on that
i think well that's great that you kind
of come
yeah they come into your life for a
period they almost teach you a lesson
and then they're gone
as quick as they arrived right exactly i
think we've all that's a very universal
experience
good one such a good one and that's
usually
in the psychological literature the
dating is usually considered
a novelty period
is pretty close to
we can say like three months is like
really interesting novelty and then once
that gets closer to a year
that's usually when it's like yep and so
usually what happens during that three
month to year process
are the most fascinating like lessons
and learnings
and that type of thing because in a
sense the quote
other acts as a mirror
to your own development oh yeah man
yeah yeah you're right and they'll and
in some ways they kind of show you
it's almost inevitable that they show
you parts of yourself that you weren't
aware of because they
are they have their own tendencies and
their own personality and
for them to reinterpret your way of
being you're putting that forth into the
world and then they're reacting to it
through their lens
there's something embedded in that
especially when you're so close and
intimate with that person
and your minds are connecting and you're
experiencing their interpretation of
your behavior
your way of being like that's there's a
lot to be taken from that too
right just having somebody with that
level of insight into you it's rare
even even the closest friends it's hard
to do that with right that's what
makes the mirror so efficient
because it's that intimate yeah
yeah and it's very important like evan
indicated
that we can treat our brotherhoods and
sisterhoods
also with that similar level of intimacy
that's right
because if you do that then
your closest your best
friends become also mirrors
to your own development yeah and so
that's
great as well i've had a quick question
for you alan um
so obviously the twin flame thing is a
is uh
new to me uh for the most part how would
you
how would you characterize it in
comparison to that term that
pop culture term soul mate do you think
it's the same thing is it similar how is
it
similar how's it different yeah that's a
good question
great question it's almost as though
like the connotation of a soul mate
maybe makes it seem very binary
yes and then the twin flame
makes it seem like we were indicating a
moment ago that there
could be a period of maybe only three
months or a year
of those sort of divine lessons that
occur between
and that's where you can you know
will create these polls in the spectrum
again you can sort of like
trip jump like people talk about you
know jumping from
trip to trip in terms of when you
take in entheogens and you never
really integrate the lessons
yeah and it's very similar with
the dating is that if you
jump from person to person and you never
integrate what the mirror is trying to
reflect to you
then
your idea of twin flame will constantly
be at a lower level than what it could
potentially
optimally be at so usually the
nomenclature
the word is a twin flame
mean something that is a little bit more
potentially sacred or divine or
spiritually
it has that tendency because it comes
from
an individual that is using it in a way
that is
not oriented towards those more like
limbic which is very similar to what
like soulmate is trying to do but
mate is so deeply binary
in a sense and it's like is this my soul
mate
are you my mate and then the the whole
thing from the other person
in that case is kind of like are they my
soul mate
you know am i going to be with you
forever
and ever and like the
whole thing of like one of the things in
modernity is that the whole idea
of 80 years with one person
is something that kind of throws
a wrench into people's uh
being because yeah that's a hefty order
that's a hefty thing to fulfill
but but i think you're right i mean
intuitively what i imagined your
explanation of the twin flame versus the
soul mate was sort of going to be would
was that that there's a presupposition
with the soul mate that there is
one and only puzzle piece out there that
will match with your puzzle piece
and then that is this archetypical this
perfect
soulmate and there's only one of them
and it is your quest in your journey to
find them
whereas i feel like there's which right
i mean there's kind of an
absurdity that's fundamental to that
notion right
whereas i think the twin flame is a
little bit more insightful and a little
bit more
i think it's still oriented towards the
right impulse like that there are people
that
will bring something special to your
life bring something
that can reflect with you mutually and
teach you things and you can teach them
but it's not so as you say binary that
there is one only
you know there's multi there's twin
flames it's a it's a
yeah speaking of flames i was like
indicator yeah so yeah
and also it might be
a cultural obsession
that
if you look at the way that
the biological
kingdoms have unfolded and
especially the way that mate selection
in the mammalian kingdom looks like
that you have sort of
mammals undergo a
a wide array of
protocols with
mating and raising offspring
and we're no different than that yeah
and so
right now culturalists sort of
choking the living [ __ ] out of
the wide array of options on the buffet
sure and saying that you must file
into marriage you must file into
soul mate you must file into one
80-year relationship where you
have kids with house in suburbs
uh yeah type and and that whole thing
is getting obliterated right now because
we come from a generation where
in the united states the approximate
divorce rate has been indicated around
50 percent
or something like that and the
modern millennial 2020
and beyond style of parenting
in many ways is like bruh
first we're not getting that traditional
bs
marriage stuff first of all we're not
doing that we're
getting into some sort of like a civil
union or whatever it may be
and then there's also a we've heard of
this
from guests on our show over the last
couple of years they're
undergoing some sort of like even
written
like future authoring style process
around their relationship where it's
like
if if evan and let's say
samantha get into a relationship that
in this case it would be like evan and
samantha both
write down what they
want in their relationship
and they write down what goals they want
to
hit in the next month two months three
months six months a year in their
relationship
yeah it's a very completely like
different
sort of like data visualization of what
a relationship even
is and then whether people decide to
have kids
a lot of people today had kids with
somebody
and then are co-parenting
yes so there's one of my good friends is
that exactly
so many interesting phenomenons in the
space
i really like where you're hitting here
too allen because
there's something about what you just
said that hits on the heart of this
issue about a few steps back when you
were talking about the planning this
kind of relationship planning scenario
that happens is
something that i've found fascinating is
is within
the idea of romance within the idea of
dating
like a life partner a romantic partner
how much of it
how much of it is premeditated
intentional
like thought through and how much of it
is serendipity how much of it is this
kind of soft romance that
we allow to unfold organically and that
isn't
intentional at all you know beautiful
yeah and and it's such
i think that issue is so critical and so
huge because people
have such strong feelings on it because
you'll find some folks that
the idea of even trying to pre-meditate
or plan a relationship
frightens them right but it's it's um
but then you get some of the the world's
greatest which is ask the why people
which is funny start with why or if you
choose not to start with why then you're
funneling into that flow thing that
you're talking about which is kind of
the art and the beauty of
like yeah why even ask what this is and
where it's leading
why not just see what happens that's
also fascinating
yeah because that's i mean even just
those words that sounds seductive to me
i'm like yeah of course i just want to
see that
so that's sexy right like i don't know
where this is going like uncertainty is
there's something i think everybody
finds uncertainty attractive right like
it's
it's just it is the essence of life in
some sense is uncertain yeah but you
have to have that chaos
yeah yeah exactly but i mean
so warren buffett has talked a fair
amount about this that he you know about
dating
well about i think i know it sounds
silly finance guy is now
on the dating stream but oddly enough
but one of the things he really
emphasized was that um
he feels that yeah your your mate your
partner's selection
yeah the biggest decision you said
exactly exactly i think verbatim he says
that yep
because so what does that tell you there
you go
and this is
clearly on the
for those that are familiar
in chapter two
of high level perception on seed theory
in this
diagrammatic data visualization
representation of your life
trajectory where on the x-axis you have
age and on the y-axis you have
actualization and you're going towards
that north star
from your birth there on the left where
you have your
basic needs that are being met that
dictate a lot of
the fruits of your life
that you'll notice towards
that more middle
area in that tree of possibility
right above where it says medium
signal over noise
there's a little
trifurcation that occurs so right above
where it says medium signal over noise
there's a little trifurcation
and you'll notice that in your
trajectory you can either
marry a motivating partner marry an
average partner
or marry an unstable partner and that
will dictate
as you see all the way there on the far
right side
that little separating line that's
occurring between heaven and well-being
versus hell and suffering
so do you want to live in higher signal
to noise do you want to live in higher
well-being and prosperity because that
decision
is so fundamental and
potentially even number one because in a
sense your
the process of self realizing and self
actualizing
so both realizing you are that that one
infinite creator
as well as realizing you have a unique
contributory artistic expression
as an individual in that non-duality
along with that your number one decision
that you'll make along with that process
is
who you ascend with
as twin flames throughout your process
and if you choose to sort of file into
the more
conservative traditional style of
marriage
and all of the both benefits and
downfalls that come with that
versus if you potentially flow into a
more
let's see where this goes maybe we
balance the why
with the art possibility yeah yeah
yeah what and this is interesting too
alan um
so i think this question has been talked
about a lot in
internet culture like this idea
especially perhaps from the masculine
point of view like
to what is
engaging in a serious relationship with
a woman perhaps a very high risk high
return
venture which i mean perhaps i would
almost say in the affirmative it is
because
you're right if you get this amazing
partner that that really
helps you uncover your own gifts that
you couldn't see
or pulls these things out of you that is
a source of tireless support and then
that you provide that for
that person as well that that i mean
that can be the essence the lifeblood of
growth and
yeah you know it's it's kind of the most
fundamental
human thing like two parties coming
together to reproduce
whether physically reproduce or you know
produce create new ideas in the world
through their
synergy and through their interactions
super doppler yeah
as i'm looking at your shirt that's what
i'm thinking exactly either coming up
together and spiraling and dancing
together right but then you get
there's some interesting conversations
that happen on the internet like the
have you heard of the mgtow movement
right one more time on the movement oh
you've never heard of this which one is
okay
this is some deep reddit stuff um you
it's
make town it's a acronym that's
pronounced uh
it's mgtow oh
but i thought that was just mg toe
i i've heard people say it on is
pronounced mgtow
apparently yeah okay and that the
acronym stands for what again because
i've heard of this community
it's very like red pill male oriented to
the community what does it stand for
again
um it just stands for men going their
own way men going their own way
which is we need to realize there's
going to be some dirty bath water oh
yeah and a baby there
you know so the baby is like yes please
like identify your
both self-realization and
self-actualization and go your own way
to focus on that
but simultaneously drain the dirty
bathwater which is where you become
so pathologically individualized
that you completely forget the ocean
that you're actually
in where you actually have a
moral responsibility to
be a strong individual in that
social fabric whether it be with a
partner
or whether it be with your business or
whether it be
whatever have you in your community
so okay well it's very it's it's very
much
it's very much of a short-sighted
solution right that this
but i think it arises from this idea
that to
an idea which i think has a grain of
truth that
as we alluded to before that the
partnership choice that you make has
such a profound
impact on your life outcome that is that
perhaps
a what happens if you just decide to
forego making that decision entirely
and just opt out of it is that or focus
on yourself more first
yeah which
i think that's the right answer yes i
agree which is basically not opting out
you've exactly focused more on your
self-realization and self-actualization
which makes you a much more
optimal mate in the dating sphere
itself and if you don't do that before
entering the dating sphere
usually what happens is you have the
attachment and you have the
uh the perverse incentives
that occur when the two people come
together
because it basically becomes something
that's more about
settling and not actually growing and
ascending
yes yeah i like what you said earlier
alan about
the there's almost a cycling up that
happens through each relationship right
that
it uncovers more of yourself and your
dynamic within a relationship
and if you you i think you were sort of
saying if one neglects to reflect
after those periods then you're not
subsuming the lessons
that can be gained you know it's it's
that's potentially the downside in being
sort of a serial dater or serial
monogamous that goes
hops from relationship relationship
without pause is that you you really do
need that
that reflection period just like
trip jumping is just like date
jumping serial dating which is just like
serial interviewing because i went
for 2018 and 2019
on an interview per day
doing almost 700 of these
and then realizing that what i wanted to
do in 2020
was abstract out the most profound
things that i had learned
into a visual synthesis which was high
level perception
which i took a whole year in 2020 to do
before moving to
los angeles and so
it can be viewed in myriad ways this
idea of
integration you must integrate
and take time to self-reflect on the
profound
teachings that you're having and if you
don't
you're bypassing the actual integration
of
those experiences which is where all of
the fruits are at
is literally in the integration because
when your partner when you're dating
point something out to you
i would have a lot of scenarios
especially
let's say five-ish years ago when i was
in my second
three-year relationship
where i would have my partner at the
time
pointing out to me as a mirror
this specific points where my mirror was
dirty
that i could that i could we had this
analogy in the
in the self-realization episode go and
listen to that one if you haven't yet
and so now you can get triggered
because this is usually what happens is
people get triggered yeah when
when and this happens in friendships as
well this happens in parents and
children
is people get triggered when someone
points to the little
dirty spot on their mirror
blind spot yeah that people get
triggered
and they don't actually take the wisdom
that is being shared with them
so for me what i tried to do as much as
i could
was take and meditation helped me so
much because i had been sitting at these
10-day theravada buddhism meditation
retreats
called vipassana which is a very direct
conservative teachings of the buddha
through asengawanka and
what it taught me to do was it taught me
to take my partner
that was teaching me something about my
dirty mirror and my blind spots
and instead of immediately reacting oh
yeah
it created that massive pause
and so i was able to really
do a better and better job over time i
literally recognized my second
three-year relationship
as the exact thing that i was supposed
to test
my spiritual learnings through
so like if you go and sit for 10 days
which i sat four times if you sit for 10
days
you should by the end of that sit on the
first one
you should notice that there's a bigger
pause between
your partner saying something that
triggers you and your reaction to it
and so then that is when you become more
and more awake because now
you're able to do things like say oh
will you explain more to me that spot on
my mirror
that you're talking about because i
would like to hear your perspective
about it
and how i can potentially become better
that was a profound change in the way
that i handled relationships
there isn't i love that alan god and
that and that everything you just said
was so familiar to me as well and like i
was just getting flashes of my own
past transgressions mistakes yeah i mean
i was the most guilty in most of my past
serious relationships of just
being always reactive to the negative
feedback
of the partner or the just yeah that the
constructive criticism even that i just
it was something that i did not know how
to
situate and to contextualize and to
react to appropriately
and the one thing i wanted to say i
completely agree with what you said and
i think that's really brilliant insight
for anybody who's
trying to engage in a relationship and i
think in some ways it represents
emotional maturity too
can you have an intimate partner and can
you
care about them enough and respect
yourself enough to
not play to your lower instincts to
react to
what maybe feels in the moment like a
tearing down but maybe there's
some truth in it or maybe maybe there's
some fruit
how do you turn that thing that feels
negative in the short term into
a flowering in the long term you know
yeah
and this is critical also to say that
the
the suggestion or the perspective
of the in this case the intimate partner
if you're dating
or it might be one of your best friends
or it might be
um some stranger on the street or it
might be
your mother or father yeah family too
family's huge here we have to remember
that
some of the times it is actually
huge love and wisdom yeah
that is trying to help us identify that
dirty patch on the mirror
and to respond in the way that
is please i would love to learn more
about that
and then now i would like to contrast
that yeah
i would like to contrast that where it's
like in a sense
there would be times in my relationship
that i was just speaking of
where it wouldn't be something like
trying to identify that spot on the
mirror it wasn't good faith
it was it was it was literally the ego
trying to pull down some
buddy in this case in that dating if you
come back from a 10-day meditation
retreat and you are quote
untriggerable the ego
is like [ __ ] i'm gonna trigger you oh
yeah i'm going to trigger you
and this is the same thing with my you
know with my mother and my
uncle family this is a big thing that
happens
oh yeah because if you want to be quote
untriggerable and the other person is
in a sense still in a more egoic or
lower
levels of consciousness as you know we
brought this up on the
on the previous show on self-realization
as well and we'll go ahead and also
we'll bring it up here from you as well
i just have to restart this game go
ahead go ahead i'm very much with you on
that too alan i think that's also a
critical distinction that has to be made
that
and maybe one of the most difficult
things to do in a relationship
is how do you assess when the person is
genuinely
coming from a place of love and caring
and
wanting the best for you and is saying
maybe dropping hints or saying things
that
feel abrasive in the short term but that
have wisdom
and when it's coming from this dark
place of insecurity in them
or exactly right i mean as they say off
people
often criticize the thing in you that
scares them you know right
the thing that they want the deepest
that they see you showing
yeah and then they get frightened and
that's usually what happens when it
comes to people that
have been self-realized is that when you
quote become god or become source or
become
it you realize that sentience awareness
consciousness
is it that we are it
when you realize that and you begin
expressing yourself from that
what usually happens is that there's a
lot of backfire from
family and it's usually what's uh or
and and even friends and and strangers
there's plenty of people that are in the
youtube comments
of our shows that are talking to me
about the quote you know direct path or
the quote
my my oroboros in terms of my
understanding of the actual nature of
reality and the breakdown of it
there are people that come on and that
call me
uh schizophrenic or call me you know
that i'm gaslighting or that
say that there's all these sort of
different
ways of of an expression
of god in the sense watching another
expression of god but they don't know
that that's even the case
they don't know that we are already that
because if they knew that
then they wouldn't have a tendency to
make a
dirty comment dirty comments come from
places
of hurt people hurt other people
that's where
yeah i mean i i i find very rarely
does do internet comments on a piece of
creative work
very rarely once in a while you'll see
somebody who says something that comes
from a place of that
probably 80 percent of ours are really
solid people in our community that are
so there's a lot of good comments where
people comment
things that i then go and look up
because they're trying to help and so
that's exactly a really good process so
i don't i think maybe in this case
there's a polarity with like
i mean jurgen has a very big audience
but he says things like i never read the
comments yeah
and then that misses a big point because
on that episode with like john mackie
like we were talking about
yeah it really felt like there was an
immersion into a little bit more
of an egoic struggle yeah and so maybe
if there are some comments that say
you know re-read baseline to a higher
level in those dialectics and you can
maybe take that feedback
and use it sorry i just want to i just
want to say this
because we've had this up and it's so
important
the sort of spectrum of
and for those that don't know this is
david hawkins and his levels of
consciousness this is very similar to
claire graves don beck and chris cowan
spiral dynamics or anybody that's
analyzing human development we talked
about this a lot in the last episode on
self-realization
but we're giving this big spectrum of
ways whether it be
dating or family or the stranger or the
best friends or whatever
where there's this big spectrum of where
the
person is trying to tell you
that through their perspective that you
have a little bit of like this part of
your mirror that's a little dirty that
you could use and you're like oh that's
an interesting wise insight let me
ask you more questions rather than being
triggered
versus on the other side of the spectrum
is literally when it's
like in this case on this graphic it's
literally shame
or guilt or fear or
any of these lower levels forceful
style levels of consciousness
that are basically trying to in a sense
drag
you down and this is a lot of what in
this
way i can i can i can vouch for this
because i've seen people that have
become
quote more self-realized
which have then fallen to the perverse
incentives of the pharmaceutical
industry
because then what happens is their
family says
you think you're god oh my god and
they're like
not realize themselves that this is
it they don't get that and so what they
do if the person especially is not
sovereign if they can't anchor their
sovereignty and distance themselves
wisely from their family's ego yeah they
will
fall into the trap of the family's ego
grabbing their elevated states of
self-realization
and pumping them with pharmaceuticals
which will then destroy their elevated
states of consciousness
i've seen that happen a lot now albeit
there are certain pharmaceuticals
definitely some nuances there's some new
there's definitely some nuance to this
but just wanted to bring that up they're
sort of
especially in dating you're going to
encounter this a lot that
you're going to have these sort of wise
intentions that are trying to help you
with the dirty part of the mirror
versus the sort of you shouldn't even
get into a relationship with someone
if during the dating that sometimes you
can't tell because people are very
as rich as doctors best behavior richard
dawkins calls it the extended phenotype
as in literally people are using the
internet sphere today
to put the only absolute
highest tip top versions of themselves
on the platforms and that's what you
that's the exact same thing you get when
you have a first
in person date with someone and so
when you get maybe into that one week
two week one month
two month area you maybe start seeing
some of those other aspects to them if
you notice those egoic tendencies
drop it right away yeah drop it i think
you are right about that
because you want to hang out with more
of your higher
levels your higher vibrations
yeah definitely dating somebody who's
narcissistic is not
i think universally that i think any
psychologist would tell you that's a
terrible idea
right um it goes for your family too
sorry but if your fam's like that take a
take a big step
back and and uh and
things will align downstream but take a
step back
don't be fearful that it won't produce
big fruit
because a lot of people have fallen into
needing to be the
the web developers of their own family
and what happens is that
it actually makes things
a lot worse at times so
go ahead yeah i think we can keep
going where you're on i had um my
thought was
so i think there's also another
interesting side effect to what you were
describing earlier
with the ability to have a partner
that prods you in the right ways and you
react in a way that's constructive
there's another side of that that we
haven't mentioned yet that and
perhaps and this could start to get into
some i'll keep it in a territory
where it doesn't have to be
controversial per se but i think there
also is something fundamentally
very attractive for for most people
there's an air of confidence that comes
with
the type of person who's able to hear
criticism
and stay grounded right like that
there's a bizarre level where that's not
only good for you because you get to
hear
this thing and entertain it and say does
this have merit does it not
but also you've you've reinforced for
your partner that you are a grounded
individual that has their own
sense of who they are and that
because i think when you choose a
partner there
people want to feel that
there is a respect for each other and
there's a bond that happens and there's
a coming together
but also that you're self-sufficient and
sovereign enough
that you're not going to become a weight
on them right
there's somebody you can run together
but you don't have to
you pick each other up when you fall but
it's not like
you can't run individually that sort of
thing right yeah
two holes have to come together
if you're trying to be a half that fits
another half it's called codependency
that's called codependency and all this
type of stuff you have to be completely
whole and that's why we were talking
about this a bit ago
which is that you undergo your own
process
of taking a step back from dating so
that you can undergo
more self-realization and
self-actualization which will then make
you much
more efficient and
driven by truth and love and wisdom and
all of the good stuff when you do enter
in there
but a lot of times the dating even
pre-self-realization actualization can
cause sort of the
tendencies for you to want to undergo
that investigative process
so like when someone actually
is being triggered a lot and suffering a
lot because of their relationship
that can sometimes trigger them to be
like why
am i so reactive yeah and how can i get
better at this and it's like okay
distance myself from the dating scene
let me go and check out spiritual
traditions meditations
neurofeedback and biohacking entheogens
all these big buffet of of options to
become
more better in that in that scene yeah
and that's in and that's maybe maybe to
put it in some terms maybe that's actual
this
actually the spiritual utility of dating
like it almost becomes
like the journey and the attempt to
become intimate with somebody almost
forces your hand to refine your own
psyche and your own spirituality in your
own consciousness
because having somebody in that close
proximity you can't really hide right
if they're an extension of you almost
right you can't hide from yourself at
that point
so there's that's an unspoken value of
that i love that that's great
yeah it's there's a
one of the probably best aspects to
dating on the
absolute best end of the twin flame
ascension
is something along the lines of when two
holes come together that are already
like very self-realized and
very independently self-actualizing
and then they come together
and then they're in a a process where
they're both
really strongly mirroring each other's
slightly dirty places on that mirror
and helping each other ascend and this
is also true for
your friends your closest friends
business partners business
partners exactly exactly you can have an
elevated state of business partners
which is like
that shit's awesome but when
they're more at the egoic level that's a
lot more disastrous
oh yeah so that's a lot to do with these
levels of consciousness being a sort of
first priority
and so at this like really good end
there's almost a
like you said each person knows how to
take
and give really good feedback and
then you know the the phenomenon of
feedback
like you're saying in a very spiritual
way it's a fascinating analogy
because the way that
individuals date and give each other
feedback as they ascend
is also very very similar to how
feedback works in terms of
you can just look at like your your
blood sugar
because your your blood sugar is
undergoing a constant feedback where
your pancreas
secretes either insulin or glucagon
depending on your
blood glucose levels and it's another
fascinating there's feedback
all over uh that works in this
style of like iteration helical
yeah ascension style pros iteration
so this is a really good way of
of thinking about dating especially is
like
becoming whole first
and then as you
enter into because this seems like the
trend like if okay if people were dying
when they were
30 or 40 years old there might not have
been enough time to really become whole
before entering into this and offspring
but
if you're living until 80 90 100 120
which is kind of where we're aiming to
head with longevity
then bruh take the
30 40 years and try and accelerate it
even faster
yeah to get there when you're 20 get to
a more
self-realized and self-actualized state
when you're 20-25 let's compress it down
and that's what we're going to do with
all of the
animations and and virtual reality
pedagogy that we're currently working on
for 2021 and beyond
because what that gives you is it gives
you an
entry into the dating scene that is
coming from a place of
i'm looking at you from a place of
enlightenment and you're looking at me
from a place of enlightenment
and we're looking at growth and
ascension together as a priority
and that's completely different than
codependence
and any of these more sort of like lower
uh more limbic more forceful states
of being you're definitely in the higher
levels of
enlightenment peace joy love which
sort of coming from that angle and
dating is going to be
much more fruitful
way more fruitful
yeah there's so many perverse incentives
that exist
in dating oh yeah
let's uh let's come up let's let's end
with um with a synthesis we're at
approaching 50 on it so
like
we already kind of gave this a little
bit ago
but just to really anchor it home
as we become
our planetary longevity
increases for each individual
you really want to focus on your own
self-realization and self-actualization
and become
whole first and then enter yourself into
the dating scene
and don't take 60 or 80 years to do that
compress it down to 20 30 get it done
faster
and then once you sort of enter the
dating scene
it's up to you to know that you know
what you see
on the extended phenotype social media
sphere
is almost certainly going to be much
different than what you encounter in
person
and then especially the first date is
going to be a lot different than
one month two months three months down
the line it's like the mcdonald's
hamburger and the commercial versus at
the restaurant right
you open the wrapper and it's this like
smashed bun
versus this like perfectly veneered you
know glossy spray painted hamburger
and then you see on the crazy
that's a good one and so
yeah because it's the same way with
marketing a product is like marketing
yourself on the
oh yeah on the mate sphere on the gram
yeah on the gram
and so now what happens is is that
you have this high level of discernment
because you're really you're taking it
from
this levels of consciousness perspective
once you begin
taking your levels of discernment from
that levels of consciousness perspective
it becomes really applicable to not only
your dating but also even beyond that
with your
business and your business partnerships
your
best friendships your family all of
those other
relationship dynamics because now you'll
know that spectrum of when somebody is
coming from an elevated state of
consciousness trying to showcase
something
a little dirty bit on your mirror blind
spot to help you become better
and you can ask good questions because
you're not as triggerable because you've
underwent some of these more
elevated states of being that have made
you
more giving you a larger pause
versus on the other side when somebody's
coming from a more
ego driven place that then
to wisely distance yourself
politely from that and so
that way you know know what you want in
these relationships especially dating in
the sense of
how much should we come into this with
asking
you know why are we doing this yeah and
uh how much of it do we want it to just
be artistic flow
if we want this to be one night or a
month or three months or a year or kids
because it can't just be a cheer
transaction either
right it can't be so hyper planned that
there's no room for spontaneity it's
going to be
exactly one year yeah and there's just
nothing sexy about that right
yeah so i mean yeah so so yeah so
there's that
and i think that's a pretty solid
synthesis of what are
those were really good core concepts
that i agree
we hung up in a lattice work around
dating that's been one of my favorite
parts about our
yeah our brotherhood we always get the
unexpected directions
and we you and i have a great dialectic
on
unpacking core concepts hanging them up
in a lattice work
and then riffing off them and riffing
off of them and you know and then my
role is now my role is i take this
and i turn it into some sort of an
actual visualization
sure a data visualization like you see
in all the high level perception stuff
and so that's one of my favorite parts
is t making something that
can be anchored and that people can
reference people can build on top of
mathematically manipulated that type of
stuff
and that's sort of what we see with
things like you know
david hawkins and and claire graves and
these sort of levels
of consciousness because now it's given
us so much more profound insight this
simple
framework of playing in it it's almost
playing all these ideas against this
table which i agree with like
i think the minute i saw this the other
day it immediately resonated with me
and i like how tangible it is that
you're able to actually assign
each one of these adjectives that we
know so well you know like reason
love these fundamental feelings ideas
adjectives
and then kind of tabulate them and put
them on this gradient
yes as relate as they relate to power
and force it's very
powerful exactly my brother very concise
exactly
and so that's what we have to do with
high level perception
and with chimps with our animated series
with all of our downstream
disseminations of high level
mimetics around enlightenment is that
we have to turn them into these really
rock star
concepts visualized that people can
relate with
that's that's that's a core principle of
ours here
good stuff bro again kept it nice and
clean 52.
yes let's wrap good job that was nice
man hell of fire
should i say one last yeah yeah this
might be okay
this might be just i i i just want to
make this reference i think is what it
is
so i know alan and i both like j cole
right oh yeah we had a moment when alan
first
arrived in los angeles where i think we
were sitting next to each other just
wood shedding grinding away
we had the jay cole on and we were just
heading on and working away
so there's that j cole song um uh
no role models right where he says don't
save her she don't want to be saved
don't save her she don't wanna be saved
don't save her
she don't wanna be saved don't save her
she don't wanna be sick
and that's interesting a lot of wisdom
there and and uh
i was just about to say we're gonna get
a copyright strike
i'm joking because i'm oh i was just
joking because
i was that was my voice it wasn't
anywhere near
j cole oh i was giving you credit but i
just wanted to just playfully just say
that because
yeah you know my abilities to on the
spot create these
you're right that's a good uh ending
point
that's a really good ending point
because i think the idea that's embedded
in that
is that you have to be in an enlightened
enough point in your
self-understanding and in your
understanding of your how relationships
need to work for you
that you can tell this person
i'm not going to change them they are
what they are they're not
where i'm at we're not meeting there's
not a meeting of the minds happening
exactly
and you have to know that you can't
negotiate your way into a relationship
like if the other partner isn't
on the same page you have to let it go
it's funny because i also feel similarly
about
my mother in many ways right now don't
save her she don't want to be saved
don't save i feel very similarly because
there is a very strong egoic pulse right
now
coming from her and my uncle around
my explorations of
psychonautics and so if
i'm going to choose to for my first time
in more than
around two years which i've played with
5mu dmt and lsd and these other
psychonautics but in this case this
anthogen
recent heroic dose of five grams of
psilocybin that i underwent
was a massive trigger and so there was a
massive amount of like disownment and
shame on from the among me and so for me
it's only a place of like straight up
god level consciousness of just love
respect
compassion but wisdom and backing away
from that
because don't save him he don't want to
be saved don't save
in business like if you're in a business
and the llc is you know 50 50 split
between two people
one person is doing way more of the
[ __ ] work than the other person
that's a very common archetype in
business yeah
and so if you don't solve that and if
the other person has a good amount of
ego
you know don't save him you don't want
you should he don't want to be saved
like
yeah exactly move on you know uh if you
if you set a goal in a month
for that person to be more on the same
page and they're not
dude break that up and go and take your
skills
to elevate your own concepts and ideas
at the next level
and find new business partners all that
stuff so it works in
all relationships like that i'm glad
that you ended with that lyric that was
that was a really good idea
yeah good stuff good stuff team
much love thanks for tuning in to this
episode on dating
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
how do you feel about dating what do you
understand about dating what is your
knowledge in the space
of dating especially in all these
different relationship dynamics that we
were talking about let us know what you
think in the comments below and drop
your favorite pop culture references in
there i
i feel like i'm slowly becoming
simulation's
top pop culture referencer right i got
whoppin
last last conversation tom cruise
current events
and j cole now i guess i gotta quit
reading all the gossip magazines but
the tally with pop culture references
evans
and the leaderboard yeah it's you and
you and uh shaker
chickenpie you guys are the two who are
on the
on the super connector leaderboard right
now it's you guys for the ones of
introductions and stuff like that so
i have a little mini personal
leaderboard that i'm keeping my own
little tallies on
but but i do i try and i try and well
because you got to know who's there
first you got to know who are the early
boys that are you know that are there
putting in the work because they're the
ones that get the most tokens
of the enterprise is super important and
that is why also whenever there are
introductions that
that happen like on the alex kanesvich
show that's happening later
that it's always like super grateful to
evan bliss for introducing us
and that way there's also this little
like guide post at the beginning of the
interview
or at some point in the interview that
says that which then makes it so that
there's like a data reference point for
um ford as well besides just my little
ledger myself
i'm learning things yeah yeah you know
you now we know more about how the
operations work here behind the scenes b
bts
of the yeah of the enterprise
all right and like the video subscribe
if you haven't yet share it with people
that need to hear it
also um that'll really resonate with
share it with them
you can find evan's instagram in the bio
below go and give him a follow
you can find our first book high level
perception down there as well go and
check that out
and support us our links are in the bio
blow so we can help doing cool things
like
continuing flourishing our dreams here
and support the other artists
entrepreneurs scientists engineers
spiritual leaders
people in your communities around the
world that you believe support them and
help them flourish
manifest your own dreams into the world
your own self-realization actualization
fullest dating and relationship
capacities
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in we'll see you soon fam
peace